je voudrais maintenant m'adresser à un
jeune invité il a 13 ans il s'appelle
frédéric il est je crois fanatiques de
science fiction et la vie depuis cinq
ans j'aimerais tout de suite puisque tu
as lu le livre d'andré révélant que tu
me donnes ton opinion sur cet ouvrage
est ce que c'est de la science fiction
pour toi ben à mon avis c'est la fosse
entre la science-fiction une sorte de
fantastique étrange parce que la
frontière oui c'est la frontière c'est
la limite pourquoi ce que tu lis de la
science fiction toi qui es jeunes
ménages et la science fiction parce qu'à
mon avis un auteur de science-fiction un
champ à un terrain d'expression beaucoup
plus vaste qu'un autre il peut créer des
situations qu'on ne trouve pas dans
d'autres romans et en plus la science
fiction on m'apporte aussi une évasion à
une distraction très grande
j'aimerais que tu me dises ce qu'est la
définition de la science fiction
frédéric ma définition de la science
fiction c'est une recherche prospective
du possible
voilà ça c'est formidable écoutez je
vous remercie dans l autre je le
rappelle donc le titre du livre à la une
cette semaine les chiens d'andré ruellan
aux éditions lattès
un livre auquel évidemment temps x ce
soit de nombreux lecteurs
[Musique]